Out here in the wild,...
...when you don't fit in, life can be a real bear.
Especially for Norm.
What good is a bear if he can't even hunt, huh?
Why don't you take a picture? It'll last longer.
But when his home is threatened...
Humans are invading our land.
Read them and weep, boys! Caribou yeah!
I want one!
He'll finally discover...
Humans are moving here now!
Look! From Florida.
...what he was born to do.
Go to the city Norm, and convince them not to move here.
We need to convince people to help you,...
...and I have an idea.
Backup dancers, let's show them who we really are.
Ladies and gentlemen, Norm of the North!
Fleming, look out!
Wait for it...
Geez, they don't call this place a concrete jungle for nothing.
Norm of the North.